welcome to this video this is round two
form of the Norway chess super
tournament and and just like in the
other or the first three carriages I'm
going to present four games quickly one
game in more detail let's get right into
the thick of things the first game I'm
going to show briefly is Hartke Stein
dr. Stein against Kramnik and let's see
what happened here
artist an with a very good start three
draws for his son for his rating in this
tournament being the clear outsider feed
rasam very good
we got an Enzo ARCA Stars playing d4
here in this tournament he also plays
one fo as I could witness in the
tournament on my Yorker this open
tournament that I had played earlier in
May about one month ago
octa Stein was a participant it's quite
funny to see him switching from the from
from from my tournament and so to say to
the super tournament okay and I was back
then he also played the e4 but here we
got an Enzo and Cromley gets playing
what he usually does the so-called cup
of variation with the double trade in
the centre and b6 um yeah you could
argue maybe somewhat more complicated
line would would have been more
appropriate to maybe try to play for a
win yeah he's playing is his normal
stuff for so to say and tries to go from
them not doing anything crazy yeah he
played the move h6 which is a very rare
move normally like a louse possible pin
here on on Bishop g5 this square he
leaves open and black is playing stuff
like Knight this
Bishop is having those kind of moves
it's a multitude of possibilities h6 is
interesting though
it keeps as mentioned a bishop from g5
dr. sands playing Bishop III after some
sort this is a good prophylactic move it
withdraws the bishop from the possible
attack by the Queen let's say Queen c7
can be a move at the later stage and it
also allows the C part of what C pawn
yeah this C pawn as black chooses to
take at some point c4 as possible so
that's a good move and now Crumley
played knight c6 yeah the the drawback
of all this is from a practical point of
view I mean black like is probably okay
here his ideas to play 97 the sister the
whole point of the h6 plan 97 and maybe
then centralized the night
pretty nice positional idea the drawback
as I started to say from a practical
point of view is the move d5 this is
played back to study and after that we
get to a position where black has
absolutely no winning chances
he needs to trade idea we don't those
kind of ideas on the Queen Queen f6 is
Foster
yeah now we have a completely open
center CD and e-file are are open and it
leads to this position where you can
already see that on the D file there is
huge pressure by me all rooks and it's
interesting after Age 3 I should show a
funny little detail does this move which
looks quite nice as painting to Oak t5
should avoid that and okay well we had
this and here Cromley started a funny
funny operation which ultimately didn't
lead any to anything
it was interesting he gave the exchange
here temporarily
and now followed up with 95 really funny
funny line young here after 95 Bishop g5
like a Scott
the bishop am and yeah there is no big
transport needs to take bishop takes and
no Queen takes yeah
they look on if I was hanging if white
tries this fancy move their screen g5 is
quite neat yeah Ruka g5 Bishop e2 went
black yes sir
yeah probably winning in the long run
with two bishops against the rock okay
Queen f3 and Queen e5 yeah and what's
the result of all this
total total equality like has some
slightly the more active position with
the Queen on e5 yeah but frankly
speaking of white place precisely that
never should happen anything he chose a
trade a against F tone and now went for
counter play with f4 against the King
and it was just in time in a way yeah
yeah yeah check check check what this
sort of potential and draw a greet I'm
also like and of course all the time
like here I'm just take yeah
Queen a3 and and it's totally dead yeah
it's just not a very suitable position
right out of the opening to play for
weakness black but scrum League is a
very principled in this way it does not
play anything yeah too risky on what he
considers to be a unsound so I was
sometimes wonder why not just for
argument's sake I mean I am playing this
and in blitz often and I'm writing this
book here why not maybe let's let's try
the hoop never
go for a complicated battle I don't know
it's not totally unsolved or anything
and it keeps pieces on the board but
okay he he has his own idea of what to
do and he's very well with the table
thusly okay I'm next game going to damn
I'm going to look at his tuple of cards
and let's see what the world champion is
doing we have an Enzo but after Knight
f3 we transpose into the Ragusan
variation of the Queen's Gambit the line
that Carlton has played there for a
number of years this line is chosen
chosen and now aged aged 6 with Bishop
age 4 yeah this invites a very sharp
battle if black ones with g5 Bishop g3
94 however this is also a risky business
yeah at first it looks really nice
because there is a double threat on c3
and and age 5 and so on but the 92 is
quite good forward yeah
there is also the c5 play and the part
of not took on c5 this is not a very
common approach which very often why
just place III this very normal looking
move then Bishop out or to e2 you know
and cancelling this is somewhat more
yeah a more complicated battle yeah we
had a quick play by black here on on
this diagonal and it was answered by
night to d2 blocking this diagonal the
a5 to you one diagonal yeah black shows
two damaged support structure bit and
then we capture on c5 yeah if we even
continue this moves a couple of moves we
get to a fairly typical position of the
pro Gozen very often black needs to give
up the bishop
before and get some sort of compensation
for that like here the slide the awkward
pawn structure on the queenside however
on the other hand white has got two
bishops black has got some dark squared
weaknesses as it is very often if you
have given up your ducks could be a
bishop and you're not very well
developed yeah
the bishop on c8 especially is not great
and you cannot easily let's say play
Knight b6 and get the bishop our des
there's always Bishop f6 happening
damaging your pawn structure so when
blacks play should be very concrete and
he played Queen a3 this is I guess a
good move it attacks on on a2 and still
looks at the pawn on c3 ya if white now
plays a passive move black would
probably play b6 Bishop a6 let's say
move like that there is there is b6
castles who should be 6 and black has
managed to very nicely get rid of his
bad bishop so the power of just ignores
all this and he gives up the a to pawn
yeah and like it really does not have
much else counsel also decided to take
it if you don't take it who asked your
your big compensation for all the Queen
moves and the bad development so he took
the pawn and now c4 was played a very
logical continuation white wants to open
up the position as as much as possible
and wants to get play for for his
bishops yeah 94 probably the best move
it it looks a bit counterintuitive to
move the same piece again when you're
behind but it's just for concrete
reasons I guess the best mover the text
the night on d2 and it invites this
structural change which is Tsar to how
to avoid we can only argue that white
maybe can play rooks it to Queen a5 and
only then take but in general we have
this this capture which will happen
yeah and now at least um the pawn
structure has lost some diner
hmm sorry and the the Knights are gone
which is very helpful if you just just
for argument's sake think of this this
looks terrible and with an idea for
black managed to get rid of the Knights
so on we come to this position and here
around here it is quite clear that white
has very nice compensation for the pawn
but it's not so clear how he really
should continue to try to to make yet to
make something substantial out of it as
a black position is still very solid he
has no real pawn weakness to attack or
or let's say we can position or anything
that is directly a subject of attack the
only thing is blacks queenís of course
always a bit under fire but as long as
it is not able to trap it not not a big
problem yes you fire force plate trying
to - yeah - to cover the bishop - to
improve the position here and also get
the bishop here out to one of those more
active squares as possible b5 is covered
at the moment by the Queen on b2 yeah
and now we see a fairly typical play by
Carlsen a5 I mean not typical of his
play but a very typical way to play in
general if you have this extra a pawn
it's very often an idea to just push it
right right right now to also get your
rook into play yeah this way you really
don't worry so much about your Bishop
being developed as you think that okay I
need to get the bishop out yeah and rook
to the aid and stuff this is not
necessary here on a 1/1 sorry on a 8/8
of course the rook is just just nicely
place because it supports the a pawn and
therefore you develop your rook by
pushing the a pawn in
right you don't need to classically
always put it in the middle of the board
of course very often centralization is
the way to go but yeah the rook has a
useful role yeah and it seems that right
here in this position T'Pol off really
does not have anything better than what
he did and what he did is not very
exciting for the spectator but you know
oath to Paulo and Carleton and we see
now after this year cards went back and
now to pull off played this sort of
perpetual on the rook and here they drew
the game which is yeah not very exciting
as mentioned for the spectator but it
seems that there is really no big way
forward for for white and knowing both
players they are both very the most
probably the most fighting players
around I mean counts and really only
Joseph he absolutely needs to and to
Paulo is pretty much the same he very
often actually sometimes it seems he
prefers to lose than to draw the way he
plays sometimes so you cannot really
call those guys like boring or anything
it's simply like there is no no big
alternative um if we look at this for
example what should Y do yeah you can
try to to to develop an initiative in
other ways but black always has counter
play if we just just the sample I this
is not for us them and yeah what should
Y do now let's say go here keep all the
pressure maybe go here yeah black will
push the a pong I mean I'm not sure
maybe maybe tupelov could have continued
but it's um it's somewhat somewhat risky
I don't know maybe in other situations
when he was feeling
I don't know in the right mood he
probably would have continued when
Calvin couldn't do anything he was just
in this perpetual maybe took Paul off
could have tried but it's unclear to me
how risky this this would have been I
mean they porn is dangerous so what
drawing this game not too exciting for
cards and for draws but as he stated in
the in the press conference he only had
played one bad game the game against
Kawana where he was very much better
spotted this and at the end was somewhat
was not lucky to make a draw but he was
sort of groveling for wrong so not not
great not great is his tournament so far
for his standards of course okay so next
game um what is the next game actually
Aronian Svidler yeah let's have a look
here and this will be relatively brief
it was a long line here of the grid
fault with Jack
Luke b1 both players have played this
several times so it could have been
expected also rupees seven has been
played a lot and it seems that we follow
a following game for rather long time
and all this seems to be known as
whittle imagined in the in the press
conference that that was all very much
known line aronia was also playing this
very quickly yeah they did dismiss it is
mysterious because yeah I look Elliot
played all this super quickly and the
resulting position is just totally equal
I really not sure what he had prepared
and it was a quite funny press
conference when when Aronian was not
really answering the question why was he
going for that when when there is
nothing
but it was what a bit weird and yeah now
after this we see that black was indeed
slightly uncomfortable because he got
the pawn on e4 which is not ideal but he
just set up a position where it always
defended twice and there is really not
much that white can try they played for
a bit yeah but aronia was playing very
quickly Jack Jack yeah here they just
went to a rook endgame aronia didn't
even bother to take yeah I mean this is
a rook and came upon up after age five
of course itself it's quite dead yeah
there's no winning chances I'm pretty
amazed that the ninja-like stock which
was supposed to be really good yeah
gives this as clearly better for white
this is of course a total joke so
somewhat strange somewhat strange
evaluation yeah well okay this is not
even what Aronian play team played g4
and it's pretty much nothing going on
it's you can you can try a king of King
f4 but after this you will get the F
pawn as trade off for the e4 pawn so
very unexcited
game and somewhat mysterious what what
Aronian was doing they're pretty much
blitzing out some preparation which
leads to a draw this white okay it's
this it seemed to me like that the press
conference as mentioned was rather
obscure okay so Cara wanna Geary Kawana
the tournament leader with two and a
half or three and Geary slightly
struggling after he lost to two Kramnik
let's see koala surprisingly slightly
surprising he plays c4 he's primarily an
e4 player nowadays not mixing it up so
much but okay here he wants to obviously
show that okay it's not going to be easy
for all the time
you also need to prepare for something
else against me okay we haven't this
kind of reverse to Dragon and trusting
me enough he plays that was with Bishop
III which is the yeah the old
traditional way to play it
in recent years mostly was all before I
think this was also played in the early
game in this tournament between Sweden
and cronic yawa Bishop III this is very
much like it is played in the dragon as
well in the in the e4 c5 dragon with
with Bishop e2 the classical variation
very often the bishop ends up here and
tries to exchange itself here and then
afterwards play on the C farm here we
are ever decided to to take on c5 and
output the knight on d5 I think this is
a fairly normal position from from this
opening or if you imagine this being a
Sicilian AK like colors reversed it also
looks looks fairly fairly normal only
after the next two moves and get some
somewhat in the interviewing g5 was
played yeah and this is really the in a
way most important move of the game
because yeah well Gary accepts that his
whole King side position he and the
Kings side is weakened in order as a
compensation I was trying to say is he
gained some time and space but it's not
really clear if in the long run
this is such a such a great decision we
will see that led later yeah this was a
typical typical way to play
with E for him white fights for the e4
square and gets it here for the bishop I
rocked here it to me at least it was
looking that like that Giri is slowly
being pushed back as some pieces were
traded and he made some progress here
Khurana did in the center yeah no they
receive five as a possible entry square
check and the round here thought oh wow
this is probably going to be at another
windfall for the young player from from
from Brooklyn he is originally I think
isn't he from New York and not playing
for Italy yeah 95 I really thought that
this should be very nice for right now
the tink position is getting more and
more of a problem and D for answer is
also week looks very tough to to defend
for black around here is an interesting
point it seems that in this position
Knight takes is 7 was an interesting
move it's not a very intuitive move to
exchange but it seems to be a very good
form concrete reasons if you look at
this Queen before just the text the rook
and what should it do it's not easy
because there's also this F 5 square F 8
square for white checks for example if
he goes rook F 7 look at this check this
is a very funny position where black is
some very close to falling in as oops 1
you cannot move the bishop cannot move
the King you cannot lose the pawn and
the Queen always must in a way make sure
that the deep one is protected and it
also must prepare first must be sorry it
must protect this diagonal so that Queen
f6 checkmate is not coming
ya really need to visualize this if
black plays or this is really stupid
yeah but just to show it checkmate let's
a made now and this is a very difficult
position for black
there are even a funny funny ideas if we
just put put some moves on the board
let's say black plays Queen c6 here yeah
then white has the the funny move right
it doesn't happen here does he i'ma TM I
was thinking about this ya think it's
possible briefly afraid that there might
be a perpetual but there isn't yeah this
is a funny move based again on this
checkmate
but this checkmate trick and yeah it's
very close that black is running out of
moves
very often white can also take and at
the end windy for with a check
yeah just a possible line Knight takes
is havin was probably interesting it is
the move from recommended by woody need
computer gives it it's almost a win for
white I'm not totally sure if it should
be winning but it looks very promising
Knight age forever with the intention to
go to a three also look nice at least
for for the humanoid Queen c5 and now
Queen f3 was played yeah he also white
has some interesting alternatives one
being the check on evade with the idea
to drop back to everyone now intending
Queen f1 a queen F to evade like yeah
infiltrating with the Queen not with the
rook what he did was he put them Queen
behind the rook and this does not seem
to be be as promising maybe rook evade
or sorry playing here maybe rook f8 was
the stronger move or Luke f6 not tried
not question but it looks more promising
than Queen f2 after this
check
um that's what's too quick after this
it's not not so clear how why should
continue maybe should should somehow
yeah regroup here to to get again the
queen of in front of the rook what is
clear though I mean what should always
be somewhat better even if he plays some
but nothing moves like I don't know
Queen somewhere everyone have to just
keep the position as this one should
always be somewhat better because of the
the bad black King position this is a
really a consequence of this g5 movement
is a very clear illustration why you
should always consider carefully those
kind of moves I really can can hit you
at the end yeah Khurana ever played 9 f5
and this is based on some miscalculation
as after this it's really a total draw
they trade it on all off and here Queen
III respect Queen c6 was also was also a
draw
yeah i TM they continued to a bit but
here simply there is not enough
firepower to do anything against the
king and this is all very precise Queen
e2 was a threat check and today here
there are only check so now check
something until they agree to a draw
because it's a perpetual buy by one side
yeah quite can give it like and give it
it is a draw yeah maybe there was some
chances for Caruana
around around the time control 9 takes
e7 and maybe later instead of Knight f5
or here
ruk evade there was some chances but he
didn't make the most most of it this
time okay so still an interesting game
and now go let's go for the game of the
day it is kayaking GUI shock and this
was a really funny game
it's on up and down game no no honey
it's the right right way to call it we
had a group felt again somewhat
different line to Iranian Sevilla the
Bishop III rooks see one line a line
that is quite often associated with
Anatoly Karpov who made very good use of
it and his third championship matches
matches I think he played in 1990 that's
clear in the New York they all match
did you also played in 87 maybe not
quite sure not quite sure but it was
very often played back our poor friend
with good success
quite often they got this type of ending
yeah with C takes and so on but black
has other ideas he can also play it with
them yeah let's say with more pieces on
the boat you don't necessarily need to
trade down to an ending Bishop g4 has an
interesting line now answer it with
Knight g5 this is also an idea of car
buffs the idea being that you play a
three push the bishop back and then
return to a three it just avoids any
trades after h6s also H also h3 h6 is
really a bad move okay Knight a six was
played dropping back here and route c8
yeah the knight urn is not badly placed
on a6 it makes sure that the C file is
open for for counter play and it can
sometimes get into play on b4 or c5
according to circumstances d5 was played
c4 ship you wanna we see that kayaking
already has spent lots of time here
despite the fact well that was still in
in a known position it's not a total
main line but still a known position but
note that
Jainism is not regular default player
normally his default player who
sometimes for the sake of not being too
predictable plays d4 see for an idea
three yeah but this like one out of ten
games not I didn't look up the
statistics but he's really not often
doing anything else then then then the
King pawn yeah so maybe he needed to
find things over the board
yeah Knight g5 was played make sensor
after c4 bishop deform Bishop deform and
now kayaking after some hesitation took
on d4
that's an interesting position really
not as he takes d4 and if you want you
can pause the video here and find the
best continuation for black it's um
there is a tactical sequence and it's
it's probably not so difficult but it's
so funny to try to find it yourself
black black to move and to find a nice
sequence yeah I'm going to tell tell it
now okay the thing is it's it's clearly
about this this sort of pinning
situation must be something like that
and in fact black has a funny technical
trick he played c3 here yeah after not
quickly really mean it was planned and
what else is there and now what happens
okay fine let's start Queen takes yeah
is a total disaster up losing the Queen
so cannot do that moving the Queen check
nope
so at the end what must take with rook
yeah now what's the big point the point
is say this check it's quite nice yes
giving a check on a square that is
protect
three times and all three captures are
our legal but okay some are easily
dismissed
Quinn takes root X of the slays easy
Bishop takes rook takes us all so just
just in exchange for nothing so it must
be played to take with the rock yeah and
Roxy one that's the big point using this
this pinion
kingi to only move check trading and
rook takes h1 so with this sequence
Black has won the exchange for pawn
yes kayaking just blundered this maybe
maybe but maybe he also was thinking
that he has some compensation
rook b3 was played and I believe that
right here in this position very quickly
after the this sacrifice we get to we
get to a critical situation at least
that it is my feeling that this is a
critical situation and we should now
played the move b5 after some hesitation
it's always a tough decision moving your
pawns because well they cannot go back
you really commit yourself with the pawn
move there is yeah there's no such thing
as a non-committal pawn move yeah and
why is b5 an interesting decision or a
debatable decision it is somewhat
debatable because it weakens the c5
Square and the whole Queen side in
general mostly c5 this is the main point
when there was the press conference room
what's Midland Aronian at the time they
they had a look at this game and they
both stated that they would prefer to
play b6 in this position and having
looked at this a bit myself also
supported by mr. Houdini
I pretty much agree b6 seems to be the
the better choice
the main point being all you you only
move the pawn because it's hanging yeah
and you need to attend to this simple
threat b6 is covering c5 it is not
allowing a piece to come to c5 quickly
and it just seems to be the the better
setup I mean black really should be
better than this position position it's
just a question of how much and in the
game after b5 I think relatively quickly
white gets pretty substantial
compensation even if the engine is only
giving it as I don't know a slight edge
for black I think that in a practical
game White's position pretty quickly
gets quite interesting f6 was played to
to cover those squares specially 95 and
now 91 here we see one point yeah
the night-sun D has a has an idea where
to go just imagine this position would
be six and this idea would be
non-existent a 5 in rooks e3 and here we
see the next point the knight to e1 also
cut off the rook on h1 so at the moment
the rook is not doing that much and
White's rook has two ideas can go to c5
it can go to the c7 after rook c8
Whitehead the smooth which never would
have been available with the pawn on d6
yeah hm it is already a bit difficult
for black not difficult in the sense of
that he's worse but difficult in the
sense of playing the position what
exactly are you doing while taking on c5
you really don't want to do giving white
this this passer on the sefa and
improving the pawn structure we should
have decided to push his pawns and yeah
like that and we get to the point where
if
you were located with with an engine it
it folds down to a zero evaluation
probably because if we look at what
happened this this pawn this b-pawn
probably has enough power to to allow
black to to free the rukia and to get to
a position which is probably drawn we
see this a bit later why does entering
here on the 7th and Roop the 8 yeah he's
just somewhat passively protecting the
bishop this wasn't the only the only
approach though black here also could
have played D to be tuned which probably
would have secured a draw immediately
but of course I think black was still
trying to do something yeah this this is
the the drawing idea after for example
b7 takes check check and this this
really should be a draw you know it's
very mean it's it's not easy at all to
to get out of the checks white can do
that but blacks rooks are active and I
don't really see a way forward here
White has no passed pawn here he's got
two pawns for the exchange that's not so
bad
but it's not apparent how he should
should make any progress but this was an
alternative but look the aid was was the
more fighting choice b7 and now rook
ahead now he returns to 8 he goes to 8
with a similar idea and it happened
check yeah he got got the e1 piece as a
trade for the before so we have a
similar situation like the one I showed
before but here the king is on b3 and
black is not as well coordinated it
still should be a draw but
it's not easy rook F to looki 7 this
pawn was taken and now this is surpass
all right it is dangerous and pretty
much demand some very accurate plain
rookie 3c for opt to this all seems to
be perfectly okay but it's already
tricky if we for example if like wants
to take the deep one is already decisive
this is too too quick the move played in
the game Rock T 2 was fine
you should be wonders really no no other
other decent square and exactly here in
this position where grease shock wasn't
severe time travel we see that the ICC
clock is really screwing up here showing
a - figure here and already serious time
travel to shock is making a mistake it's
super easy to do
and this is really the problem of this
way of playing the way he played is some
sort of a position where why it is much
easier to play as you you have the the
active possibilities here with your D
pawn the active rook and black must
defend very carefully and sort of
walking a tightrope to avoid to avoid
defeat yeah what he played it looks
totally normal really rupee - attacking
the the bishop but it seems that this
move is really losing instead the other
attack rook e1 was was better it is also
very tricky though if we look for
example after d6 which looks very
dangerous the move rook 81 is the one
that that is drawing
and it's not not easy to see king c5
yeah and exactly here black and black
and take note that this is not possibly
wine is winning like that booty I can
take and after d7 sexy to check this is
a funny perpetual on those those squares
it's very very difficult to calculate
all this in any case and if you have
little time it's it's pretty much
impossible
you played rugby tune and what's the big
difference now d6 is coming much quicker
there is no perpetual idea in this some
in this configuration black cannot take
this is just just promoting played King
f8 and now Bishop d3 was played it it
seems that here even Rupa takes h7 was
good and even stronger than bashad b3
but this was not easy to to spot it's
relatively easy to see that this is this
is win as Luke h8 and d8 Queen cannot be
prevented
yeah well black can't do this but yeah
this is quite obviously winning for
white with him attacking the rooks and
having the the pass I am or the
passports the F pawn is very difficult
to to to keep king can also enter only
six rook h7 let's let's check again King
e8 as a possibility
the bishop es toe with just one of any
square so this is an interesting as well
and yeah here it's interesting that
right here you can drop to d3 and just
have snatched the H born in the process
Yahoo KH 7 was was
somewhat stronger but okay now in this
time it is very very difficult to play
rook t2 and Bishop f1 this is a strong
rook takes h7 is not enough it looks
interesting at first like that check
it's quite funny actually d5 but it is
still a draw even this is a draw check
check and black will stop the D pawn can
even think here this is no no way to win
many checking possibilities as well
yeah Bishop f1 is some is strong and it
still should be very close to win from
white rook edge sadness mentioned was
was a bit better but it's still probably
winning look III was played and yeah
what else is they can go into e1 but
there there is king c3 this was a very
important move to to foresee Luke DD one
and Bishop b5 and finally the white
bishop is getting into the plane I don't
really I cannot really analyze this to a
total conclusion I can give you a sample
line that looks fairly fairly and
logical and now something like d5 is is
quite strong white at the end of you get
the pawn on going
check check check
and after this and at the end this
bishop will switch to this important
square on e6 h7 will probably fall it's
a very good position very close to a win
probably this winning but it's hard to
start to determine absolutely surely but
from a practical point of view this is
not defensible in any case why it just
has a much better plane and here
here probably it is really also winning
from a mathematical point of view let's
call it like that mm-hmm
sorry d7 and king c5 that's very
important of course threatening to set
up a meeting attack with King D 6 which
pretty much forces black to play King c7
and now finally white took the H pawn
yeah Black has no defense anymore we can
continue for a couple of moves t g5 yeah
what happens if black cam goes to this
guy goes to c2 to setup the pin this is
not a problem and the white hazard has
an overwhelming position combining
mating attacks with the attacks on the
pawns and then the passers for example
like this jack yeah and why this coming
coming to the weak pawns
yeah why this white is completely
winning him it's just simply no defense
yeah g5 was played and here we have like
the similar situation what sacrifices
his um his pass or to break through
check this was played in the game it
here Grisha resigned
yeah suddenly a somewhat frustrating
game after the the start when yeah he
had just won in exchange but it turned
out to be a fairly tricky position and
in my my point of view is that after b5
it is tricky for like not not not bad
for black but it's very tricky to play I
think probably with b6 it was possible
to really establish an advantage after
b5 only a couple of moves later I really
don't think that black has anything even
if the computer gives them a slight edge
it's it's so it's somewhat hovering
between equal and 0.4 for black but what
does this really mean
the thing is white is just much easier
to play and it's not so clear that the
engine is evaluating this correctly note
that the black rook here is not doing
very much
it's it's really incarcerated here and
the the play happening on the queenside
is not in any way supported by the rook
so maybe it really is just just equal en
around here but equal in a way that
still demands super precise play
especially from the black side and with
little time agree shock I couldn't
couldn't do it really so win inform
Tarkin and loss for Greece shock who is
on 50% now so he's got the same scores
as cards in the darkest night with all
the drawers but he has got no draw two
wins and two losses yeah ok this was the
fourth round of this tournament not a
super exciting round
I must admit many draws with some what
yeah I don't know not so much action but
still some interesting points
to watch yeah I hope you um we'll be
back tomorrow to watch the round 5
coverage I'll be back and thanks for
watching